hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar automation aided targeted
genotyping with allegro for maze
breeding a case study of qtl analysis
with magic mapping populations i'm susie
valdez of labrutz and i will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrutz and brought to you
by tcan to learn more visit them at
tcan.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speakers dr
davide scaglioni
the chief technology innovation officer
at iga technology services and joining
him will be dr leonardo caproni
a postdoctoral fellow at the institute
of life sciences at the santa ana school
of advanced studies in pisa italy
welcome gentlemen you may now begin your
presentations
hello everyone thanks for joining this
webinar my name is david escallion i'm
the cto of egotec and today i'm going to
present
on automation-aided allegro targeted
genotyping for mace breeding a case
study for qtl analysis on magic mapping
population and today the presentation is
going to be
hosted by
chu uh the first part is going to be on
me i'm going to present you more on the
technology
uh and the
auto the implementation of the automated
platform
uh while on the second part leonardo
caproni from scuola superior santana
will give a
better insights into the analysis of the
data
so a very quick
a very quick introduction to igateka the
company i'm working for
we have as a main mission
to provide technologies and methods
based on sequencing
uh
to improve
the health of human animals and our
planet in general
and among those uh
of course we
we foster
the preservation of biodiversity
uh
and also the improvement
of uh agriculturally relevant crops
and of course to do that not only in the
algae biotech field we need to maintain
a quite wide portfolio of technologies
and methods
and not only also analysis and so we
range from the novel assembly of plant
genomes
down to genotyping exercises but also we
are serving for epigenetic studies
metagenomic studies
and also some
single cell
analysis of transcriptome and epigenome
[Music]
after having said that
genotyping is one of the application we
are running the most
because now with the sequences
sequencing based genotyping
the demand has increased
quite a lot during the recent years
as you can as you know genotyping is
the art of sampling the diversity in
large court of samples and it can have
many applications
which goes through plant and animal
trade selection
association with disease or resistant
genes
sampling the population diversity and
analysis of structure of those
population and identification of
adaptation patterns to
to
understand how
plants
or crops are or can adapt
over the climate changes that are
occurring to our planet
and um
all of these applications
need need different level of resolution
to to cope with the with the goals
uh for example we can run from just a
phylogenetic analysis with a few
hundreds of markers
while association studies might require
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
markers
and so the flexibility of a genotyping
platform is one key element to be able
to provide a
cost-effective solution
to
a quite wide range of uh
scope of analysis there are basically
two main platforms that have been seen
running on the market in the last years
with the long run of array-based
platform that have been proved to be a
very robust
system for acquiring genotyping data and
now in the recent years
sequence based genotyping and in this
presentation we are going to focus on a
very specific solution from dkan which
is the allegro target genotyping
despite the robustness of array-based
platforms we can
we can make a comparison uh in favor of
uh sequencing based genotyping by
several aspects array-based platform are
unmodifiable arrays so once the array is
designed and manufactured
it's very hard to
implement
with additional markers or scale up and
down in the number in the number of
assay polymorphism it does require a
specific instrumentation to be read out
and it also asks for a higher commitment
in term of
sample number when the array is designed
from scratch
and also the the design per se requires
a good snip catalog to
to sample from to design the array and
that brings us to the concept of
ascertainment bias so the selective view
of those array so
the the array will be designed a very
specific set of polymorphisms and only
those polymorphies are going to be
genotyped
through the experiments using that
specific array
on the other side
sequence based genotyping
especially the allegro system
uh
provides a modifiable system which can
be
changed over the time by means of the
probes of the genes that are targeted
it leverages the ubiquity of ngs
platform and their continuous cost
decrease
it does not require a very high
commitment in terms of sample number and
as well
the panel size can be
really scalable from hundreds of plus
psi up to hundreds of thousands of loci
and being a sequencing based
platform it does remove
the ascertainment bias problem so
every read
will
along with the target polymorphism
whether those are selected uh it will
provide the discovery and genotyping
in the span of 100 or up to 100 or up to
300 base pairs
just to give you a picture on how the
system works so pretending that we have
a known snip that we want to target by
our panel
um
probes
that are basically primers long primers
are designed upstream of that
site and they will provide the
priming to the extension event that's
why the technology is called aspect
sequence single primer extension
technology
uh and so
those extensions we generate
uh template molecules that are going to
be then sequenced and as you can see by
the picture yet you're going to extend
over the target side but you can also
discover new sites that were not known
uh
before
that's all uh it's all a measure on how
long the reads are going to be if they
are going just to be
75 base pair for example
you will probably just genotype
mainly target snips but if you extend
your sequencing up to 250 base pair
you give a lot of room to
the novo discovery and genotyping
the scheme of processing
of allegro genotyping is pretty simple
you work on plates so on a single sample
basis
for the very first two steps of the
procedure
which are fragmentation and ligation of
adapters
ligation of adapters carry the
the first molecular barcode that are
it's going to tag each individual sample
within the plate
then there is a cooling scheme uh on a
two tire approach which leads you to
having a single tube per plate
then with that on on that single tube
per plate
um the enrichment the single primary
enrichment is performed so you you you
will enrich for the target loss side
and after what after that
another a final pcr enrichment step is
uh
is scared to
[Music]
provide the final libraries with the
dual indexing scheme so you basically
introduce the second index which will
discriminate
place
one one one another
we have already published a couple of
seminal papers on the technology
a first paper
that came out on analysis of botany and
presented
a comparative study of allegro
genotyping with the illumina snip chip
by using
mace inbred lines and hybrids to compare
the robustness of genotype calls
and another paper on frontiers in plant
science published by barking co-worker
where we were involved in the genotyping
of thousands of
eggplant and tomato accession so i
suggest you to give a look at those
paper because they really prove
the effect effectiveness of the
technology in providing large genotyping
data sets
so we implemented this technology on a
fully automated platform thanks to tkan
we have
just recently installed the dream prep
which is this cool automatic
liquid handler in our labs
uh it carries uh an on deck thermocycler
and the plate reader so it's capable to
carry
all the ngs preparation without moving
samples out of the
deck
with the current scripting that we have
in house we can process for the allegro
preparation four plates a day
without moving anything out of the deck
so what we wanted to do was a stress
test
test sorry
and
we prepare
564 samples
uh divided in six plates
of these
maze magic lines
and the
prop panel
set that was used was a 50k
design
actually selected from a previous final
pilot design and those were designed on
zmi's assembly before
so what we did is for plate one
um everything was carried on the on the
deck up to the pulling stage
and then we we move the rest of the
processing outside
of the of the deck uh that is on the
bench
for plate 2 plate 3 plate 4 and plate 6
we run everything on the on the liquid
handler on the dream prep
but for plate 3 where all this or all
the
thermic cycling
were carried uh
on other thermocyclers so that is the
fragmentation ligation
enrichment step and final pcr
uh were carried without using the
on-deck thermo cycler
and the plate 5 instead was completely
processed on the benchtop
here you can see the profile of the
libraries
they are different
uh in looking at the analyzer but
finally when we align the data on the g
on the reference genome
you can see that
all of them has a quite comparable uh
fragment size
the only outlier here is plate one uh
which
unlike the others were which had a
median of about 300 base pair
uh plate one
recorded um
a median
fragment size of uh about 500 base pair
which this is the plate that was
processed half on the on the on the
liquid handler and half on the benchtop
the first performance value that we
wanted to assess was
the level of enrichment across
plates and preparation
as you can see here
uh regardless of whether plates were
processed on deck
on the bench top
or
half away
[Music]
the percentage of raw reads that there
were finally informative in providing
coverage over target loci was always in
the range of 70 to 80
which is quite of a
very important result because if you
compare any other ngs technologies i
think you will find hard
to
[Music]
to see uh
libraries with such a high amount of
reads that are actually
actionable reads for
the scope of the analysis
if we then look at the distributions of
coverages across
probes
we can see for that for plates
one three and five which are the plates
that reach
exactly what was
intended to be the target coverage we
have a similar
pattern of uh
variation
uh we instead have a much higher median
for play 2 which was on purpose over
sequenced
while for plate four and six uh you can
clearly see that they are lagging behind
this is because
we have not yet completed the uh
the sequencing for those so please be
reminded from now on you should consider
the entire data set
as
not very complete because we still need
to get some additional coverage out of
those two plates
here in this big distribution you can
you can see a plotting
of
all the genotyping events accepted by a
stratification of threshold from a
minimum of 5x coverage up to a maximum
of 30x coverage for each sample given
the amount of reads that have been
generated for that sample
uh if we if we take as a first
[Music]
point of view a minimum coverage of 5x
which actually was enough for this
experiment because i recall that
we are genotyping homozygous maize lines
so 5x is already a very robust call
for a homozygous individual
here is where you start to
move from a poor genotyping
cluster
almost to a
a good level of saturation of the
library
is rich by having generated
about 40 cluster
if you want 80 reits
per probe per individual
while a much higher level of saturation
which can also be at that point
considered valid for
a minimum of coverage of 10x and 15x
is
where 120 cluster
per probe per sample are generated on
the sequencer
and then you can consider there here 200
cluster per probe as
as a complete
saturation point
where
regardless whether you are looking for
genotyping at 5x or 30x you are only
always on top of the
of the recalling ratio
of course it's a met it's a trade-off of
cost per data point there
we assume here to be already on a good
spot
when
the number of clusters per sample per
probe
are within these two landmarks easily
around 4 million
reads
sorry 4 million fragments
here it's a more more detailed view if
we split the data across place if we
look only at data from plate 2 which is
the over sequence plate we can see that
all the data points are completely
saturated
and
and there is a
very high coverage of genotyping
actually more than what is needed in
term of cost per data point on the
contrary
plate 4 and 6 are still in the slope of
reaching a good saturation point and
that's why they need more sequencing
data to have at least
an average a median of 4
million fragments per individual
so what we have got so far is that out
of this panel of 50 000
loci
uh in this magic population we yielded
more than 47 000
target size to be polymorphic and along
with those
we also yielded more than
247 000
of target sites being polymorphic
if we then put down some constraints and
thresholds in the in the in the
genotyping recall
uh
by looking at those sites only
genotyping a minimum of 384 samples and
yet you should consider that plate 4 and
plate 6 are lagging behind in in terms
of coverages
with the minimum genotyping coverage of
3x
more than 43 000 target sites have been
genotyped and at the same coverage
uh
more than 200 000 of target sites
polymorphic have been genotyped of
course if we if we increase the coverage
to 10x we see this number decreasing
not significantly
uh
but uh
we knew that for this type of population
being
nearly homozygous
magic uh
inbred lines we don't need
much than uh discovering the single
haplotype being inherited in each line
so with this data i leave
the podium to leonardo caproni to
continue on the analysis of these data
points for gus
and quantitative traits these sections
thank you very much
and thank you davide i'd like to now
welcome leonardo for the second part of
the webinar today welcome leonardo
thanks
and thanks all of you for attending this
webinar
so i am uh leonard caproni i work at
scala super de santana
and now right before i tell you
something about our case study
let me briefly introduce uh the group i
work with at squalas update
as you can see from the background of
the picture there's the leaning tower
scuola super de santana is located in
pisa
it is one of the three universities in
the city
and it is an honors college here you can
see
the crop genetics group
and
we like
to work with cereals
and
we explore genetic resources and
we like to work on quantitative genetics
to develop tools for modern breedings
however we also work a lot with
landscape genomics
in the development of
new breeding approaches for smallholder
agriculture in developing nations
and we also work with multi-parental
populations
so now we can start talking about
multi-parental populations that are
extraordinary materials to perform qtl
mapping
uh
however
before i start talking to you about qtl
mapping i thought it was a good idea uh
to give you a brief recap on ttl mapping
within plants and i must mention
uh mapping using my parental recombinant
in the blinds populations
so here as you can see
in the picture
what's
the principle behind qtl mapping in my
parentals populations is that you look
at
the diversity within a certain species
if you're looking for a specific trait
you should find two very divergent
individuals for that trait
so what you do is you cross these two
diverging parentals p1 and p2 in the
picture
and then you obtain several two-way
hybrids and then you start like selling
their progenys
and
for six to eight selfing generation and
what you do is you end up with a
population of recombinant red lines that
you can use to map your trades
however
this approach has
several limiting factors
in fact you may not be able to map other
trades as these populations are built
upon a certain trait
so
what you can do you can also perhaps use
association mapping in which you take
the wall
or a very good representation of the
diversity of the species you are working
with
and you try to associate
the phenotype you you measure
with this
broad genetic diversity but you totally
ignore
the parental information you totally
missed the pedigree
so to bridge the gap between
mapping using by parental recombinant
word population and association mapping
here we have multi-parental population
the most popular and powerful designs
are num
and magic
so for nested association mapping
panels num what you do is you basically
produce a lot of my parental recommended
redline populations
but for each of these panels that you
produce you use a recurrent parent here
is in this scheme is indicated in light
blue
the other very
popular
um
multi-parental design is multi-parent
advanced generation intercourse the
so-called
magic populations
so uh what you do with magics
it's basically you try to recombine the
genomes of multiple parents
you can have 4 8 16
initial lines
and you end up basically with uh an
inbred germaplasm which is actually the
mosaic of the genomes of the initial
parentals
and
it constitutes an enduring resource to
perform qtl mapping as you can map
many many many trades
so now we start talking about our magic
mice it is an eight-way magic that was
first published in 2015 here you see the
multiple inward founder lines
that were crossed using a dialectic
cross design
and uh
after crossing two-way four-way hybrids
obtaining eight-way hybrids and after
several generations of selfing of single
seed descent we obtain a panel of
reels that are mosaic of the founder
genomes and as you can see
we find we can
find a lot of phenotypic diversity
um
well i told you it is an eight-way magic
but actually uh there is a ninth parent
which is called
cml91 which was
introduced uh upon the failure of the
two-way
hybrid b-96 by hp301
and was
this hybrid was substituted with
b96 by cml91 to compensate and to
recover
the
the failures of this
cross
so
why our
magic population is such a powerful tool
to perform qtl mapping so here from the
work of 2015 of matero de l'aqua
here you can see
we use this 529
magic lines which were
genotyped using a sneak peek chip
we had circa 50
000
snick markers and we were able to map
this
uh qtl of poland shadow and chromosome 8
so nothing special you see you see the
peak
but
however if you combine
these data with
world genome sequencing
data and or
transcriptomics data of the founder
lines
you can
go within
your interval on your chromosome and
this information might
can help you in dissecting the genetic
mechanism behind the trait and you can
start looking
really at candidate genes that's why
these are great genetic
resources to map qdl of any complex
trait
now
we are using
our magic mice within the framework
of capital i this is a horizon 20 20
funded project
and we're dealing with photosynthesis
related traits so we want to map
photosynthesis related traits in three
main crops in maize barley and tomato
and to do so
we are using high throughput phenotyping
facilities as you can see in the picture
this is actually our
magic mice population being phenotyped
at ibk 11.
why
a liquid genotyping for the magic mice
so within this framework of this project
we had the chance
to
produce new genotyping data on this
population
and we choose
allegro technology
because
it's it's
very important to target specific region
because
you can capture the most rare and
informative variants of course if you
have some preliminary information i am
talking about world genome sequencing of
your of the founder lines of your
population at least you might be able to
overcome
the biases due to
some array designs
as davide
you know was mentioning you before
so
we decided to evaluate our
new data sets
by looking at the number of snips
passing a very strict qc
try to understand
if we can overcome
the bias due to
[Music]
the design
and uh we looked at snip density and the
distribution and we finally were able to
test
the discovery potential of our new data
set on a subset
of samples our population around 300
through gus
not qtl mapping because still
we need to produce
more sequencing data
and
after that we need to produce a genetic
map which still lacks actually so
uh we need to improve the coverage
and our aim today is to test the
suitability of these data sets to move
forward with qtl mapping
so
if we compare
allegory genotyping with the bit chip
yes we were able
to increase by threefold the number of
snips and we used for both
uh data set quite strict uh quality uh
control parameters by sites and by
individuals as you can see
here and in order to compare
the real number what we did is
we use a subset of samples which have
both
genotyping data and also
a subset of rails that also have
phenotypes
so next we wanted to look at the ability
of our new set of 160 000 snip markers
to avoid any bias due to marker
selection based on a small set of elite
genotypes so
within our founder lines there are
also exotic materials
as you may see from the two neighbor
joining trees on the left this one
is represented using our new set of snip
markers and this one on the right
was produced using our old set of
markers
clearly we can see that uh before if you
look at the right panel we had quite
limited ability to distinguish between
some founder lines
and this made our life very hard and
attempting to reconstruct the genomes of
our recombinant imbed lines to perform
qpl mapping
most problem arose
you see here in red between b96 and
cml91 and between h99 and w153r
these biases are due on the fact that
the beat chip we know is mostly designed
on
other two parentals actually of this
panel which are b73 and and mo
one seven you see in dark red and light
blue here
and uh
and this uh of course has has uh like
negative implications
in the left panel however we can observe
a much more favorable situation as we do
not observe any bias so our new marker
set can definitely
separate our founder lines
which makes us really happy
for the downstream analysis in qtl
mapping
snip density matters yes even if we got
many more markers when we compare
allegro versus the bed chip we should
also be careful and look at the
distribution of our snips along each
chromosome comparing the two datasets
here you see in the picture and looking
at the average snip density here we are
looking at the window of
200 to the bases we can observe a much
more favorable situation with their
labor genotyping and a much
much
higher density of snips and this would
help us a lot in the downstream analysis
especially in the attempt of
reconstructing the genomes of our
recombinant inbred lines to perform qtl
map
okay so now we are ready to test finally
whether
our new
genotyping data set
is good for the discovery of interesting
genomic region linked to some of the
phenotypes available so as i mentioned
before we have a subset of circa 300
recombinant in red lines that were
genotyped with both methods
and these wheels of course also
underwent phenotypic characterization
back in 2015
so what we did
we explored 2g was using
this method developed by you and
colleagues
that actually
you know allows to
prevent some model over fitting and
controls false positives so it's quite
refined regression for geos
and
what we see here
you see highlighted in red we have the
same
old
you know signal on chromosome 8 the one
you saw on poland and here we are
testing pollen shed
and
but what we see
we also see
other six regions in chromosome 1 2
4 5
and 6
and
so it means that
with these new data sets
we may unlock the discovery of new
regions
when we
we will perform ptl mapping
we did the same test
using another very important phenotype
grain yield
and if we look at the data of 2015
here we see on chromosome number six
here
uh a very
uh
you know evident peak
and we see the same situation here with
our new data sets so this
of course these are two different
methods and what we we can see here we
got a significant signal
uh highlighting the same chromosomic
region
on chromosome six
but we see also a very interesting
pattern
in chromosome number seven so even if we
are using less samples 300 here and more
than 500 here
we are able to detect the same region
so we might have we may have potential
discovery of a new region in chromosome
7 here
uh so to conclude
i have to
remark that
for our side
using allegro on dreamfab uh
gave us an increased statistical power
we have more snips we have promising
marker distribution
and this will help us a lot
for our haplotype reconstruction
and we do not observe any bias
and we corroborate our previous qt
mapping results and yes
we got evidence of potential discovery
of new region even if we are using so
what's next within capitalize we still
need to finalize our high group with
phenotyping experiments and we need to
develop a genetic map for our magic mice
currently we are refining our tpr
marketing pi plan and then we will be
ready to perform
our qtl analysis and map photosynthesis
related trades
so as final remarks on allegro on dream
prep we must say that it removes
people's overrate platforms
it has very competitive pricing for
example as it leverages at most
uh the continuous drop in costs of next
generation sequencing
it is a flexible platform and it also
accepts continuous improvement
and very importantly
we must mention that it can become a
community asset
once you have a
pro panel you just need a sequencing
machine and you're ready to go
so
allegro technology and
dream prep automation
can bring reproducibility and speed to
the next level
so before i finish i want to acknowledge
my group especially mario di goper
master de la croix and
i thank you all for your attention
thanks
and thank you so much davide and
leonardo for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar and if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so let's take a look
gentlemen it looks like we already have
some questions coming in from our
audience members
first question
why using targeted genotyping and not a
wgs approach
um okay i think i can take this one
uh well
targeted genotyping i think it's
the most valuable approach as long as
the genome size is still big and this is
true for
most of the
agriculturally relevant crops
uh
whole genome sequencing can be
a way to do genotyping
but it can beat
uh on the cause side only if you're
dealing with very small genomes like
arabidopsis or
everything that is basically below
500 megabases
and yet you might see a a
convenient scene going that way
but
genotyping
on a targeted way
ensure you the ability to get very
robust data point on very large courts
and which is
not that trivial also on a whole genome
sequencing approach because if you're
going to do whole genome sequencing
i think you're going to opt for
scheme sequencing
and there still you might get biases on
the representation of the genome and you
increase the amount of missing data and
this can be highly detrimental
in
association studies you can deal with
missing data points
uh but you need to be able to impute
those data points and this is feasible
only if you have a reference population
to impute against
so
to have clear data points
targeted
genotyping is still
strongly
[Music]
preferred because
whole genome sequencing will replace
targeted genotyping only
when the sequencing cost would be
another order of magnitude less than the
current cost
thank you very much now our next
question
is which automation platform was used
for the allegro genotyping and why was
this approach chosen with decan
as mentioned in the presentation we used
the
dream prep which is actually
a
specific setup of the fluent
the fluent is a is the latest uh
automation from deacon
as liquid handler
and
dream prep is
the the setup which i think is the
middle size fluent
with incorporated the uh thermo cycler
and the plate reader we choose that one
because uh well this is a more of a
of a company story a
t can
merge with the
new gen technologies and nugent
technologies formally developed
allegro system
and
now they are directly implementing this
solution over their liquid handlers so
we have
quite of a straightforward uh support in
implementing this system in our lab
thank you so much and
leonardo do you want to add to either
one of those questions
yes i would like to add something
related to the first question that
davide answered
so why using target genotyping and not
world genome sequencing approaches
so uh looking at our population i mean
uh
uh like when you're using uh
recombinant inbred lines
uh
of course it would be extremely good to
perform vol genome sequencing
sequencing on the wall set of
recombinant in red lines but that would
mean to invest a very very
a lot of money because actually the the
genome of mice is extremely big
uh so i'm i'm talking about our
situation it's around 2.4 uh giga bases
so
the idea and the
advantages of this population is that
you can
perform targeting targeted genotyping on
the recombinant inbred lines
and perhaps you
you you may produce word genome
sequencing on the founder lines
and uh once you you're able
and and you uh to reconstruct to
reconstruct the
the mosaics
uh within each of the chromosomes
uh related to the genomes of the founder
these mosaics can then be inferred
from snips
and
then you can infer
with world genome sequencing actually
the the real condition within within
those um chromosomic regions
i don't know perhaps i i have been a
little bit
confusing but the idea is that you can
impute
uh you know the the real state
uh within a certain chromosomic region
using the world genome sequencing data
of your funder lines
so there is no need to to
to use world genome sequencing on
recombinant in red lines this is the
point i wanted to to tell
thank you so much for adding that
piece and
gentlemen how many samples can be
prepared for sequencing in a working day
well depends on
if you implement automation in your lab
or not
in our lab basically with automation we
have been able to process uh
up to eight plates per day
um
it's a matter of
working
on the deck or not i mean you can
parallelize more if you have a battery
of pcr machines
to do
the
pcr steps
or the incubation step well actually the
incubation step is not uh limited by any
platform
at all um
but that's the point so far in our in
our lab given our needs we have been
able to run eight plates per day which
is already quite of a sizable amount of
samples but i know
from deacon that
they have also developed
combined solution involving multiple
liquid handler doing separate steps of
the
of the of the process and they can scale
up to
multiples of of the eight plates we're
doing here with the single robot
wonderful thank you very much and i want
to thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
we have time for a few more what is the
advantages of using recombinant
inbred lines for identifying regions for
the genome linked to traits
okay perhaps i may i made like comment
on this question
so actually
the advantage is that
like using the pedigree information of
each of your recombinant inbred lines
you cannot you you can actually
map really precisely
in a certain chromosomic
region uh your trait of interest and
what you can do
with these populations once you identify
a certain chromosomic region
you you you can
go
further
by looking at uh
uh and performing association mapping
with the world genome sequencing data of
your founder lines within that specific
region
and what you can also do
uh with recombinant imbed lines
population
uh with population such as
as our magic mice population you can
also use uh rna sequencing data and look
at the pattern of
uh of genes
within that region so what what you can
basically do
like more than association mapping
is
is that you can really look into a
certain
defined chromosomic region and you can
really dissect
uh the mechanism behind the trait you
are studying this is the the the true
advantage
and uh of course using this population
you can
use and reuse
all the genotyping and phenotyping data
in
in the years in the years to come
i mean it's a
it's an
indeterminate resource and uh
uh
of course
this has several advantages in terms of
costs and in terms of uh
you know adding quality to the to the
results you carried out in the past
you may add further information in the
future
okay thanks
thank you so much gentlemen
we have time for two more questions our
next question how does allegro compare
to genotyping by sequencing
i would take this one
this is actually a very important
question for those that are not familiar
with the targeted genotyping
standard genotyping by sequencing
is based on restriction enzymes
and there you randomly sample the genome
without any specific
target to be selected
um
this is uh
it was a very good uh first step in
using the genotyping
this are using sequencing as a
genotyping platform
however
it has several limitations
one of those is that if you have a big
genome
and you want to find association
for phenotypic traits
uh usually those mutation resides within
uh well they reside within or close by
genes
and so you want to yield
genotyping data points that are in genes
or at least nearby genes
and if you randomly sample let's say 30
50 000 loci using standard gbs
technologies
uh
you don't get the statistical power
because you are too far from the
causative mutation and the linkage decay
will cause you the loss of completely
complete loss of the statistical power
this is one aspect the second aspect
is that gbs is hardly reproducible
because uh the
the
selection of loci of the genome that you
are going to
[Music]
take uh
in the sequencer uh
strongly depends on uh well of course
the restriction enzyme that you can
reproduce as long as you know the
protocol but also the size selection is
a very uh
pivotal point in the procedure and
whether you select for a small fragment
or large fragment you change the
population of loci so it's very hard to
reproduce
across batches
if you don't have a very robust protocol
and very very hard to reproduce across
laboratories while instead like allegro
genotyping once the prop set has been
designed and shared it's it will work
the same way across several labs and
several operators the same way and you
keep having recall across the same loci
yet on top of interesting gene
uh targeted genotyping can also be used
to
to focus your genotyping not across the
entire genome but maybe to do fine
mapping on a specific chromosome arm so
you have complete flexibility of choose
where you want to get your genotyping
data points
and and not talking how useful can be
for extremely huge genomes such as wheat
or
gymnosperms
thank you so much we have time for one
more question gentlemen what are the
benefits for this genotyping approach to
be standardized and how can this be done
uh
oh well
the the benefits of course is to
try to develop uh
to democratize the genotyping uh in that
sense like uh
leonardo was mentioning before
now the sequencing capabilities are
going to be
a much more distributed uh
asset across labs academies uh research
institute
and so on
so the the proximity to a sequencer is
going to be much more democratic rather
than a genotyping facility
and
allegro genotyping is quite of an
example where
as lo as the prop set the design
of a specific panel is shared and
independently acquired by many labs
those many labs have the capability to
reproduce exactly the same experiment
uh because well the protocol is fixed
and
you can get an extra layer of uh of um
to to ease the process by having the
automation but even if you do it by hand
on the benchtop is still a reproducible
um
protocol and then the locites are going
to be genotype are going to be exactly
the same of those done in another lab
and this can
can be a facilitator on building on
communities of uh
on genetic resources in general
gentlemen thank you so much for your
presentation today and your time would
you like to provide any closing remarks
to our audience before we go
um
i think that
uh one
one effort one should do when
when
considering developing
uh arrays
is uh the
the number of samples that are going to
be uh genotyped and the expected uh
coverage like i was mentioning before
because this is a is a pivotal factor
that where we are
on a daily basis consulting with our
clients
to decide the amount of coverage and uh
to make the experiment the more cost
effective as possible
uh
also
i i want to mention that uh
targeted genotyping uh is is worth doing
uh when you have to do at least
let's say a couple of plates of uh of
individuals otherwise the
the design process with it
it's more costly than than
the saving percent
gentlemen i want to thank you again for
your time today and for your important
research
and i also want to thank lab roots and
our sponsor tkan for underwriting
today's educational webcast and before
we go of course i want to thank our
audience members for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time thank you again
take care bye